I hate intraocular ooh
episode 1 our story starts out at Haku
private academy with the first scene
showing the main character real this is
Zoe who is more of a side character and
a tense game of poker he's up against
Marisa Tomei who's either stressed or
her brows which is surprisingly
difficult to tell in this anime Zuzu he
thinks he has a winning hand with a full
house but to his dismay meri actually
has a royal straight flush so he ends up
losing this loss puts him in debt to
marry and since he can't pay he has to
become a house pet I'm sure this looks
pretty demeaning at face value but I
think there's some glaring perks some
people would pay to have this kind of
treatment here did using the cliche
transfer suit at jovani you may go
because she is near she needs somebody
to show her around and who better to do
that than the class rep who just so
happens to be Tsuzuki you Mako appears
to be nearsighted and Suzuki appears to
be lacking the social development to
enjoy a hot girl in his personal space
we've all been there but then we got
over it we'll just chalk him up to a
late bloomer he takes the time to
explain that gambling his big deal at
the school and to be careful if she is
approached by anybody wanting to play
but she seems rather open to the idea
almost to the point where it's
off-putting before long she's approached
by meri for a friendly game of
rock-paper-scissors but in this version
of the game spectators draw
rock-paper-scissors on a piece of paper
and place it in a box the contestants
take three random cards and decide which
one to play from there they play a
couple of the rounds and Yumiko ends up
using all of her chips which was around
a million yen she has to play one more
round and drops ten million cash it's
then revealed that 21 of the 30
spectators are actually helping Mary by
casting certain votes
Emiko picks up on this but decides to
play anyways Yumiko ends up winning
which puts Mary in debt Susie who was in
debt to Mary was in charge of giving
signals to the spectators on how to vote
you McKay I realized this as well but
ultimately forgave him after the game
was over he plans to leave the school
kids he's sick of being in debt and
treated like trash so you Mako gives him
money to pay off his debt allowing him
to stay around
yepez ode to the obvious friend-zoning
happens earlier than expected we then
come across Mary who's being bullied by
the rest of the class because she felt a
kitty status or house pet status in the
school hierarchy you have to pay the
student council to get a higher ranking
so the only way to improve your ranking
is to gamble the bottom 100 students in
the ranking are labeled as house pets
kitty for females and doggy for males
the system was implemented by the
student council who are comprised of the
best gamblers after this explanation
Yumiko is approached by sumeragi utsuki
who is the first year on the student
council because she paid her way in she
challenges Yumiko to a game of carts and
únicos like hell yeah the game is double
concentration where two decks are Flo
faced out and players take turns
flipping cards looking for a match in
both suit and number
if you find a match you get to go again
Yumiko loses but begs to play one more
round so Mikey is open to the idea but
if you make a loser she wants her to rip
off one of her nails for a collection
that sumeragi has of people's nails who
have lost to her which seems completely
normal to just carry case of nails
around with you all day pattern emerges
as sumeragi is also cheating Yumiko I
had picked up on this a lot my care to
find 54 matches on her first turn ending
the game without somebody even being
able to play game because starts popping
off excited to play another round with
both of their nails on the line somewhat
I could get scared and rejects this
offer after school Yumiko goes to find
somebody to gamble against masuzu Ian
toe they come across Mary who had just
Lawson is now 46 million yen in debt to
a mysterious woman Yepez oh three we
jump back a little bit to see how Mary
law is putting her in debt this was an
official match which is the only thing
that houseboats can do they can
challenge anybody we can only do it one
time so typically they challenge student
council members with large bets in hopes
of getting out of house pet status we
get an introduction of Nisha know to win
your to go who is a member of the
student council eudeco challenges you
may go to a game and Yumiko being Yumiko
accepts they're gonna play the same game
that mary had played against her called
life and death the place that sorts any
cup and shuffle them on the board the
board has 30 members and players guess
where the swords are gonna land it's
like rule a except the swords can land
in slots placed or on the board if it
lands face-up the verdict is life and
you win 30 times the original wager but
if it lands facedown then you lose 30
times the original wager the pattern
continues one year to go is revealed to
be cheating also the dealer is using
magnetic piercings in her hand to
manipulate the sword placements this
trick can't be effective 100% of the
time so Yumiko decides to play one more
round she takes an unorthodox approach
betting all four to give her chips on
one number if the life verdict lands on
24 the noumic hope will win two billion
170 million yen with the stakes so high
the student council president has to
come in to be arbiter for the bet when
the board has revealed Yumiko was
actually wrong in her guess and ends up
losing 310 million yet Yumiko has the
theory that the Lyford had landed on 24
but the president had another magnet
that even Yoda ko didn't know about
move the sword out of 24 so that Utica
would win this makes Yumiko want to play
against the president after the loss
Yumiko falls to house PES status and his
victim to the other students but she
doesn't really seem to mind
[Music]
episode 4 both Mary and Yumiko receive a
life program from the student council
the live programs outlined their future
life of having an arranged marriage and
kids
the politician they're not able to pay
back their debts they'll be forced to
follow this plan paying with their
future instead of money he would thought
he's a stand-up guy and isolates Yumiko
and then demands she takes her clothes
off and that threatens to rape her in
response to this because she made me
batty steps in she pulls out a big-ass
revolver and what's the Yambol that if
she shoots and there's no Bullock he
would thought he can rape her instead
but if there is he gets shot after they
seem less than eager me thought he
changes the rule stating that they can
shoot at her besides she's mentally and
stable and just end up leaving because
so many students get too far into debt
to ever pay back the syrian council
holds a debt exchange game there are
four players in a group and whoever
finishes first gets the least amount of
debt and whoever finishes last gets the
most amount of debt players who finished
first will also have the debts pay for
them by the student council Marian
Yumiko are in the same group and Mary
explains that she has an idea
jump add to the game and the rapist is
in their group along with Iran and girls
who bombing an ami the episode 5 halfway
through the game it's revealed that sue
Bowman is actually working for the
rapist because she's in debt to him Mary
knew about their likely alliance and
that's why she teamed up with Yumiko in
the final round sue Bellamy has a
winning hand and will overtake first
place from the rapists if she plays it
he's trying to intimidate her into
folding while Yumiko uses erotic
reinforcement to help her stand up for
herself she finally decides to stop
being oppressed by him and plays her
hand overtaking first place or so it
seemed but Yumiko and mary had switched
debt values before the game this messed
up the value of the chips that they're
originally betting with so when the
standings are revealed mary was actually
in first place in the end rape has
finished 4th place and is now 310
million yen in debt to the student
council Sam o Cusimano Sai om hasta que
ni by anna TOA
mary gets a check from the student
council for 260 million yen which ends
her house bed status on the other hand
you make Howard finished third and takes
on an additional 30 million yen of debt
Mary gets grew up by Yumiko marking the
official start of their friendship
episode six
even though Mary had given Yumiko money
to pay off her debt she still hasn't
done it suggesting that Yumiko is trying
to keep her house pet status so that she
can challenge the president the student
council performs a background check on
Yumi Cohen reveals that she might
actually be very rich she lost both of
her parents and is paying for her sister
to be hospitalized at a university
special word for a long time which
suggests she has a lot of money to do
this the student council picks up on the
fact that Yumiko probably isn't paying
so that she can challenge the president
after hearing this meet Rd jumps into
action to prevent her from challenging
the president because she wants her to
herself
Mary is approached by the president
asked to speak alone Yumiko is searching
for the president but get
to intercept it by me Dottie who take
her to zoo e captive they need some
kinky undertones which explains the
handcuffs
he thought he explains that if he Miko
wants to gamble the president she has to
gamble with her first
Yumiko is pleasantly surprised and eager
to take me daddy up in her bed over to
marry the president offers her a
position on the student council but she
doesn't respond the last couple of
scenes are of Yumiko losing the first
round and meet dotty preparing the
shooter episode 7 me daddy is ready to
shoot you Miko but when the revolvers
were shuffled she got you Miko's gun
which wasn't loaded we get some
backstory about me daddy and how she
lost 300 million yen to the president
and ends up paying the debt with her eye
during the second round Yumiko wince and
she goes to shoot me daddy and me daddy
gets off on this but doesn't get shot
yubico could tell by the weight of the
gun that it's hers because there's no
bullets in it the last round ends up
being Italian so nobody gets shot
Yumiko explains that my daddy is
actually just trying to die and she
hates people like that mean that he
falls in love with the Yumiko after this
reaction over to marry who repeats the
student council position and when she's
asked why she doesn't answer the
president thinks it's because she can't
ethically support the house pet system
when in reality marriage is once revenge
on the student council for putting her
in house best status before the episode
a we start out with the introduction of
a new character yumemi to yumemi
who is an idol and a member of the
student council the president is leaving
somewhere but nobody knows where she's
going in light of recent games he Miko
has played the student council members
are trying to figure out what to do
about her
my muta starts acting in the president
stead and allows you may meet they to
take care of you mokou-san she's
confident she can swim it I get to keep
makes her reappearance when she wants to
help Yuma ko beat the president and take
her position after her lost Yumiko
sumeragi was removed from the student
council she figures if he Macao becomes
the president she can get back onto the
council you may meet a issues the
challenge to you Mako and Yumiko always
accept so she goes to meet with her
Yumiko loses she will have to form an
idol group with you may meet a and if
she wins that she'll get 50 million yet
however during the meeting Yumiko
exposes you may meet there with the
letter that she received proving that
you may meet a actually hates all of her
fans as an idol yumemi day admits that
the allegations and Yumiko seek early
records it the stakes are raised to a
few mokou wins then she will release the
recording
episode 9 for the bet they will compete
in various games and when they win they
place a mark on a board they have to get
three marks in a row like tic-tac-toe to
win the first challenge is a singing
contest which Yumiko wins securing the
first mark on the board human meat is
holding back to making more of a show
for the attendees a few more rounds are
played in Yumiko ends up on match point
the next game is fan appreciation they
both rolled dice to find a seat number
in the audience then both will guess the
birthday of the fan and whoever is
closer will win you may make you think
she won because she rigged the game by
only letting members of her fan club in
for the show but sumeragi actually helps
a zoo and Merrigan and you mokou manages
to roll marry seat number and of course
you may meet it doesn't know Mary's
birthday so it's a 50/50 that Yumiko
ends up winning they played the
recording for her fans to hear but they
end up not caring and supporting her
anyway
after a short performance humic oh calls
out whoever gave her the letter and the
recording device human meat a speculates
that it could be the one who helps set
up and rig this event man Yuda he claims
he didn't do it so Yumiko challenges him
with the C at stake
of course he refuses because she has
nothing of equal value to put at stake
so she uses her privilege as a house pet
to initiate an official match episode 10
we get a quick look at the president who
is having a meeting with the heads of
each family back over to the official
match the game is choice poker which is
almost the same as poker the difference
is you can't fold or call whoever has a
higher wager can also decide if the
winning hand is stronger or the weaker
hand there's also no limit to how much
money you can bet to earn this privilege
they play with 10 million yen ships so
Yumiko uses her debt to get 31 ships
whereas man you don't gets 100 chips
Yumiko wins the first round putting her
at 42 chips in minuta at 89 and the next
round Yumiko makes a weird play by
sending back to tens after thinking
about this for a bit my near two decides
to show his hand to lure Yumiko into
betting Yumiko being Yumiko goes all-in
mining you two raises one ship so that
he can decide whether the winning hand
is stronger or weaker immediately he
says stronger hand wins because of the
two tens that she had sent back this
pays off and he wins making Yumiko out
of chips
game should be over but she asks him
Araki for money so that she can keep
playing still wanting to get back from
the student council soon what idea
grease on LAN Jie Miko one hundred chips
to play with the episode 11 the
president who was still in her meeting
begins to insult and antagonize the
other members the official match is
getting back underway with a hundred
shape donation to Yumiko
for the next round Yumiko does the same
thing as last round and sends back to
Queens they go to the wagering ground
and each player keeps raising the pot in
an attempt to get the right to decide
whether the weak or strong hand wins
this keeps going until eventually Yumiko
goes all-in Mon Yoona raises again so
sumeragi adds ten more chips to the game
to raise and of course he MCOs getting
her rocks off watching this unfold after
a while somewhat like he reaches her
limits and can't raise any more so
Yumiko suggests betting her life with
the life program after some reflection
she decides to do it and bites off her
nails to show her fortitude which is
kind of an incoherent thought process
but I mean they're betting their lives
so I guess the logic isn't really the
theme of the show my nuta says that this
isn't allowed but it ends up being
decided by the vice-president that it's
fine custom what ie is the daughter of
the CEO of a massive toy company it's
decided that her net worth is estimated
at 10 billion yen my nuda says that she
doesn't have the authority but it's
revealed that the vice-president was
actually the president in disguise my
Newt is convinced that he's gonna lose
if you Mako gets the power to decide so
he bets his own life
he's next in line to become vice
minister of finance so he's valued at 10
billion yen as well and on that note my
near to gets the right to choose any
commits of the sronger hands
when the hands are revealed minuta has
the three of a kind and Yumiko has the
three of a kind as well in jacks so she
wins
mom Yuda has a kaneki transformation for
some reason Yumiko and the president
exchanged some lesbian vibes and then
they decide that they want to gamble
[Music]
cibecue cookie cutter yeah
yep is so 12 the last episode is the
showdown between Emeka and the student
council president lolli cons rejoices
Arun and yo Mizuki is the acting referee
they both agreed the stakes will be
whoever loses will never set foot in the
Academy again the game they're gonna be
playing is called tarik carts of fate 22
tare cards are placed in a circle and
each card has a number on it from zero
to 21 which will act as its core if it's
upright from the perspective of the one
who drew it it'll be positive and if
it's upside down it's negative three
people will flip the card and the total
of the three cards will be added
together if the total is positive then
Yumiko wins and if it's negative then
the president wins but the last card is
to the fool which will instill when
Yumiko the game if it's upright and the
same for the president if it's
upside-down the game starts in Yumiko
draws the magician in the upper high
position for positive one point for the
president's draw she gets the reverse
world which is a score of negative
twenty-one points that brings the total
to negative twenty putting the president
in an e run lose ball position the last
draws to zuy any notices a mark on one
of the cards which is the same blue as
the president's lipgloss the only card
that she touch was the full so that's a
card that it had to be but he thinks
this could be a trick so he picks her
animal instead
[Music]
[Music]
he ends up picking judgment in the
upright position which has a score of
positive 20 bringing the total is a zero
and ending the game in a tie
neither the President or Yumiko has to
leave and it's never revealed if the
marked card it was actually the full
Runa is talking on the phone about
Yumiko with Devi komomo balmy a relative
of the president and in the last couple
of scenes the president dis pans the
student council that's pretty much
everything that happened in season one
so I hope you guys can go and enjoy
season two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]